dude straight into it i love it
it's dark man it's dark
lumos
what do you think you're doing here oh
oh dude the music welcome to hogwarts
legacy
you're a new student at the famed school
of witchcraft and wizardry with a unique
ability to manipulate powerful ancient
magic hidden in the wizarding world
you'll need to uncover what's behind the
return of this forgotten magic and who
is seeking to harness it to destroy
wizard kind as you may be the one that
decides the fate of the entire wizarding
world
but before you can study magic and begin
to solve these mysteries you must create
the witch or wizard you want to be let's
go dude
when you arrive at hogwarts you will be
sorted into one of the four hogwarts
houses gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw
or slytherin after you settle into your
dormitory yeah
with your housemates in the common room
you will then need to attend classes and
you do have some catching up to do as
you were starting hogwarts late as a
fifth year so you are the new fifth year
confirmed you'll begin your studies
attending charms defense against the
dark arts herbology and potions classes
to name a few
oh hello
class
please welcome the newest rose in our
garden
shall we begin welcome to year five of
chance now this will be a crucial year
in your education on the art of charm
work but i am confident that we'll take
hold with a passion and rigor requisite
of such a challenge
the best way to practice is by dueling
we'll start with youtube
time for a proper hogwarts welcome
[Music]
doing
is one of the most challenging and
hazardous subjects taught at this school
here you'll meet your professors and
learn to cast spells grow magical plants
brew potions and more in between classes
you'll be oh my gosh
famous for its secrets
enchantments and mysteries
you'll discover dungeons and secret
passageways
dungeons
as well as challenging puzzles that will
require magical skill and a clever mind
to solve
[Music]
you may even find yourself in iconic
locations you've never been able to
explore before ourselves let's go
oh no way
no way the late 1800s so while the
common rooms and classes may be familiar
most of your professors will not be
however you may recognize a few faces
once patrick yes me join the headless
hunt i'll be right there with them this
offering is sure to win them over oh
don't forget why i'm here sir
you'll come to know this eclectic group
of talented witches and wizards in class
and while completing side assignments
that are part of a special curriculum
one's designed to help you catch up with
the other fifth years at your own speed
that was quidditch that was quidditch
confirmed opportunities for adventure
abound in the area surrounding hogwarts
the magical abilities you learn to
master through your schoolwork will soon
become tested as you unravel a dangerous
mystery by working alongside the
accomplished and yet enigmatic professor
fig to try and discover if the rumors of
a mounting goblin rebellion hold any
weight
of rebellion if hogwarts lies in the
balance i have we called it differ as to
how great a threat he really is
loyalists are capable of so much more
than people realize the wizarding world
of this era is fraught with dangers
creatures corrupted by a magical force
powerful goblins
and sinister witches and wizards all
willing to fight even kill to achieve
their own goals
in fact there's an uneasy alliance
between the goblins and dark wizards
you said you could get to the child when
they came to hogsmeade but all you
needed was a distraction i gave you a
distraction i just watched a student
take down your distraction
you're not telling me but perhaps you
shouldn't involve yourself with that
just yet
[Music]
it keeps going
[Music]
i wonder what's going on there
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
and theory or skeletons
the knights
oh my gosh did you see that
he just launched a sword at him
roast with incendio
devastate your enemies using various
finishes
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest
what
mixing and matching dozens of spells
will let you define your combat style
dude this guy is dominating
perhaps you'd be good enough to blast
each other to pieces on your own time
in addition to classes and spells you'll
have access to a deep set of upgrades
talents and skills to aid your
progression as a wizard complete
challenges throughout the world to earn
experience level up your abilities by
choosing talents to upgrade your spells
plants and potions i just can't process
that
it's so much talents best fit your
playstyle to allow you to focus on your
favorite types of magic
you can also loot buy or craft your own
magical gear
that will increase your offensive and
defensive capabilities in combat
gear can be upgraded and specialized to
allow for greater abilities for your
chosen play style use a strong even
motion when crossing your ingredients
spells are not the only tools at your
disposal in combat as you hone your one
skills you can continue to further your
magical education there's just so much
regretting your development as a witch
or wizard
brew potions that can increase
a boost
i love how he's holding it in the hand
too
and deploy magical plants to mob the
battlefield and keep your enemies at bay
no freaking way you can even unleash
deadly mandrake seedlings to
incapacitate unsuspecting enemies the
mantras
in beast's class you will learn about a
variety of magical beasts you might
encounter both at school and as you
explore the world surrounding the castle
and its grounds the goal of today is to
remind all of you how to maneuver on a
broomstick what's golden
learning let's go white
so that you may travel around the world
more quickly
i want you to do my herbology homework
you're despicable
what
all companions taught to you by students
who become your friends
as you develop relationships with these
schoolmates they can accompany you on
your journey as your companions
and over time you'll learn their stories
ah i love that
this is our chance
natsai onai is a brave adventurer driven
by the justice she seeks
poppy sweeting has a kind heart and
loves magical beasts connecting with
them more easily than with humans
what happens now unafraid of detention
or breaking the rules sneaking in the
restricted section again it's sebastian
that was peebs slytherin
with a troubling family secret nothing
can the sooner you accept that reality
the better you'll meet these students
and more as you explore common rooms
hallways between classes and regular
gathering
areas to be in right
had to be in there
one of the most remarkable secrets of
hogwarts is known as the room of
requirement
you're introduced to this space that
seems to sense what you need and then
provides it for you
since you need to catch up to your peers
the room provides space for you to sew
and harvest plants brew potions
upgrade your gear
a helpful house elf named deke helps you
discover the variants that allow you to
nurture your own menagerie of magical
beasts what is it
zeke isn't sure
only one way to find out
oh i love that guy already to reflect
your personality
magical specialties
what
it's like newt's case
except even bigger
not everything you need on your journey
is available at hogwarts oh my god
nearby wizarding village of hogsmeade
where loads of shops and vendors can
provide you with the supplies you
require
from potion ingredients and recipes
to seeds how many hours is this game
gonna be guys
oh let's go
but hogsmeade also has its dangerous
side a band of dark witches and wizards
emboldened by the turmoil of the times
wander the village outskirts
you must avoid them or defeat them
as you explore you'll find the world
surrounding hogwarts is alive with
activity day night cycles of unusual
interest
yes dynamic seasons and climates will
fill the sky with lightning or sunshine
or coat the ground with snow or rain
unique wizarding hamlets pepper the
countryside
each with vendors and residents who have
stories to tell
and missions with which they could use
your dude
this is why the game was delayed be on
the lookout we're seeing why magical
puzzles that may very well have been
designed by merlin himself
when he was a student at hogwarts
magical beasts roam the lands outside
the castle walls some have been
corrupted by a mysterious dark magic
while others are at risk of poachers and
their traps poachers we called it you
can rescue them and restore them to
health in the room of requirement
but there are dangers beyond your
understanding gringotts in the world as
well done let's go let's hold perilous
threats and also untold
rewards be careful where you choose to
explore as it may lead you down a darker
path
oh my
no spells
befriend new allies journey across a
landscape never seen before uncovered
they did it in secrets combat mystical
threats they actually did it long
forgotten mysteries become the witch or
wizard you want to be
as you leave your unique mark on the
wizarding world
here
in hogwarts legacy
obadicadabra
confirmed
[Music]
holiday 2022.
that's what i thought man
i should have stuck with my gut
even though i thought maybe sooner maybe
sooner what do i think i dude i'm i'm
blown away i really am i think it's
clear why the game was delayed
um
i'll have a lot more thoughts when i
when i have time to like break it down
and make a video of it
here's what i will say
a thousand percent because obviously i
mean it's one thing to show off a game
right
it's another thing for it actually to
play well for it to run well and for
them to do all the things that they're
promising on
but i will say like just from a
presentation standpoint
from what they showed from what they
talked about they get it
they get it
they a thousand percent get it there's
there's no doubt whatsoever that they
get it right i mean they
everything they said
was
i mean made me feel a lot better i think
they totally get it
gonna lose so many hours
hogwarts legacy said your mo right i
mean we got a little work to do i think
now
fell off the chair dude miguel i think
the biggest jaw-drop moment for me
is when they they showed a vodacadabra
they showed avada kadabra
because that is something like in almost
in any video i post about spells or like
the freedom of the world things that we
want to be able to do people always say
they always say the unforgivable curses
they better be in
they better be in
and i was always kind of like
maybe you know maybe
it'd be hard to do and i still think
it'll be hard to pull off like you got
to be you got to be very careful about
how you use that right
vada cadaver got me chills yeah i think
that was my biggest type moment because
i i just couldn't believe they
they confirmed that you know
jaw-dropping moment and i'm just gonna
kind of run down some of the things that
they things that i can remember
um quidditch i think is all but
confirmed
i think i think they 100 confirmed
quidditch even though they didn't really
go into detail we saw it very briefly
confirmed avada kadavra
mind blown moment
confirmed uh seasons
confirmed day night cycles
all of those things right there those
four big things
those four big things are going to be
very very um
positive with fans i mean that's we've
been asking exactly for those things you
can go back and look at all the videos
that were made about
things i want to see and all four of
those were definitely on there the
common rooms are the common rooms yes
they showed all four common rooms i was
wondering i was like how are they gonna
do that
and not annoy people how are they gonna
show
are they gonna show off our common rooms
are they because then the teaser they
just show gryffindor
customization tom yes of the room of
requirement
that
like see stuff like that's a bit of a
curveball
things that i mean obviously we thought
room of requirement was going to be in
but then you like go in and you can just
like
i don't even i don't even fully i'm
gonna have to watch that i have to watch
the whole thing back but i'm especially
gonna have to pay close attention to
that part
because it's like they talked about you
go out and there's poachers and you're
gonna have to rescue some creatures and
then you can bring them back kind of
like newt's little case and then you
take them back to the room of
requirement to nurse them back to health
but then you get to like totally
customize that whole area
castle looked insanely gorgeous it did
yeah don't have a favorite moment
menagerie a beast yeah no mention of
multiplayer no much of any kind of co-op
which again they've never confirmed that
they've never
i don't even know they've really hinted
at that that's been mostly a fan thing
myself included i felt like that would
be something that would that would that
would be in but we'll see we'll have to
wait and see obviously they don't want
to show everything despite how much they
showed today
but they did talk about that's right j
ross they did talk about companions
which i i want to dive into that a
little more i think that might be a
little more
limited than we were initially thinking
which is not a bad thing but um i feel
like they're going for more like fully
fleshed out characters like they
specifically called out a couple
different characters in each house
so rather than it being sort of like
random you know a list of 10 and you can
pick three it sounds like they might be
set so it might be a little bit more
like persona in that regard i don't know
if any of you play persona games they're
awesome by the way but
um they have you know it's kind of set
you can then sort of determine which of
them you want to take into battle with
you but anyway
castle looked good combat looked chilled
uh the day night cycles right
am i gonna use the unforgivables oh dude
you know i gotta do multiple
playthroughs
i gotta do multiple playthroughs uh my
first playthrough will definitely be
good as a gryffindor then i might like
go back again and play as an evil
ravenclaw or something house elves yes
yes limit lad house elves confirmed that
was a big one oh uh mobile god good
question holiday 2022 so a lot of times
companies will use this to say basically
holiday means late november or december
usually
usually every now and then you'll see it
get pushed out to like january
but the fact that they're putting that
time frame on it holiday 2022 i'm
expecting it to be like a a late
november game so it's going to release
in that you know in that very
it's been a popular time for games to
release for many years world building
spell casting customization from legend
legendary
how about that light like calling down
lightning
there were so many things with those
with the bat with the spell battle that
i'm gonna have to go and look at
there's one moment where our the
character like takes one of those swords
from the night
the knight the sword's like approaching
in midair takes the sword from the
knight and like just hurls it back at
him
oh epic
ancient magic cynics what's up welcome
cynics what'd you think dude what'd you
think
the magical creatures bit they did talk
a lot about that they did talk a lot
about magical creatures
and the friends having their own stories
yes so i think i think they're wanting
to focus on a few specific stories of
these companions that we're gonna have
and go more in depth with them yeah i
love the castle i love the castle we're
gonna have to go and break down all the
creatures that they showed they showed
the house elves in the kitchens
oh
i love i love the house elves dude
i thought that was a great moment we're
also gonna we also learned about uh
professor figg
was that his name right fig
we saw him in the initial trailer he's
the one that sits the little uh the
sorting hat on our character so it looks
like he's going to be sort of our
um like
oh my gosh i can't even think right now
he's gonna be our
what's the word like our mentor that's
it that's what i'm thinking
diagon alley
yet they did talk a little bit more
about
how big the game was no mention of
azkaban today
again they don't want to reveal
everything but no mention of azkaban
they a thousand percent showed a shot of
gringotts though that was absolutely
gringotts where they were riding in the
cart
a thousand percent gringotts i'm
wondering how you get there if it's a
specific story moment because they
talked about how what really made them
keep expanding the world is how they
were like okay if i'm wandering around
the hogwarts grounds then they were
saying to themselves what's over there
what's over there what's over there what
i'm doing in elden ring right now i'm
not saying it's going to be that big
it's elden ring don't say i said that's
not what i'm saying but it's sort of
that same thought process of like okay
you're out there wandering this world
and then you see this open oh wait
what's that over there you know and you
want to go check it out notice the fact
that um did you notice the fact that he
could see thestrals do you think it has
something to do with the storyline
that's a great question and they i think
it was one of the ladies that was
talking she hinted at
they didn't go into our character about
why they're starting so late
but they specifically said like
why they're they're wanting us to kind
of wonder why are we starting late so
clearly they know that's something they
have to answer and i think she
specifically said like what what you did
what your character did i think it's got
to be something to do with that ancient
magic so it'll be interesting to see
though if our character started another
school or if maybe they were a muggle
maybe they were a squib who knows but
then they talked about even having some
gameplay things to kind of catch our
character up to speed how they're going
to have the extra activities for our
character even though because they're a
fifth year because they're starting late
it did go so fast right
it went so incredibly fast
so they're still shooting for holiday
now it seems like that was the kickoff
of
we're gonna be posting regularly now i i
don't anticipate us having to go 420
plus days again for new information
i feel like they're going to be
regularly engaging with the community
now
and i just want to say if any of any of
the avalanche people are watching
chandler or if anybody ends up seeing
this
congrats to you guys honestly like
honestly just just this part alone
obviously you're not across the finish
line yet and we're going to help you get
there don't worry but um i can't imagine
how monumental this day is for these
guys i mean when you think about some of
those devs who've been there since the
beginning of this
when this project first was first
started like chandler talked about how
he came on later
uh i mean he's very recent onto the
avalanche team
the the folks who have been having to
say nothing on this
for
years i mean imagine working years of
your life
and you can't show anybody what you're
doing you're like yeah i make video game
you can't even tell if you're working on
a harry potter game
but then finally the league happens we
finally get the announcement and then
just silent i can't imagine how hard it
was for them because believe me they see
the stuff online they see us crying and
whining and moaning and saying is the
game dead is it ever coming out
so finally guys finally it happened
so i appreciate every one of you who are
hanging out here man this was fun this
was a blast and uh it's only it's only
gonna get even better from here right
we're going to have even more content
even more things to talk about even more
things to break down so
yeah guys i'm glad you all seem so hyped
i'm hyped as well can't wait to break it
down even more with you so um as always
thank you all so much for watching guys
i will talk to you again
soon